I didn't know that I could sleep that
would have been a problem not at all
yeah i'm home more and my kids are much
more sick of me than in the past it used
to be like i like guys never around now
it's like he's still here you know when
he's gonna leave i'm finding ways to be
just amazingly unproductive I mean when
I'm busy and I'm working I much more
production or you know and I'm turned
into a bit of a bad desperate housewife
like I you know my wife asked me to be
there when the blinds a guy shows up to
install the blinds and I said they're
watching I don't probably don't have to
watch them install the blinds but I
don't really have anything else to do so
might as well feel accomplishment and
some you might as well learn were made
well that's right right I also take a
trip I went to Africa to go Laura pick
it there I you know no one really got it
I have a friend in la is a writer who
runs a non-profit and he said you know
let's get outta here and go do something
the betterment of the world and we went
to Kenya and spent two weeks they're
working for his nonprofit which that was
the one productive thing I've done
during the strike yeah but it's hard
weird being out of work you know
especially when like I've had a job for
12 years oh yeah absolutely like I'm
shaving six times a day which may be
unnecessary but you get a feel time your
skin looks good then sure thank you the
picket line is a funny place I've never
done anything like that no no it's very
very surreal the very first time I when
they actually you know gave me the sign
I was like well so you really do yes
that's exactly you just walk around and
it's important to do and it is very
necessary and it's also a great place
for social network it is it's also
incredibly boring like on TV it looks
much more fun than when you're actually
it's you know that for four hours of
just walking in a little circle I mean
if you're at the movies with your
friends you know waiting in line for
four hours there's no way that you want
to wait line with him for hours yeah you
know and I resent the LA writers a lot
because they back in December we were
picketing it was snowing like half
snowing everything yeah wheezing yeah
they were giving up these uh plastic
sort of garbage bags to just pull over
your head right um and hot cocoa and
cookies but the people in la were
walking around with seven degrees yeah
this isn't so bad I think there are any
people online Matt I met the guy who
wrote a little miss sunshine and he was
a neat guy to meet and to talk to you
I've met some of the writers from the
other shows and it's it's that stuff is
fun I think TV writers you you go into
your show and you kind of work in that
bubble then you go home and everyone's
kind of run their own bubbles so there
isn't that much you don't really
interact with right or some other shows
it's actually kind of neat to meet some
of the other people you just might
rather meet them at you know a cocktail
party here something then when it's 12
degrees outside
one of the very first times I went to
pick it I actually was there walking
around doing the thing and then someone
stepped in line and said I was one of
the strike captain said can you go hand
out leaflets oh I could it's terrifying
but we were in Wall Street the wall
street area so there I was walking like
in the great canyons of wall street just
walking around people who you know
probably make 65 70 thousand dollars a
year and commuting from Staten Island
take the ferry and you're working in
their jobs 10 12 hours a day you know
and I'm saying they're asking them to
support us because we make a lot of
money but were looking for more uh-huh
and I felt shocked at how people really
like they see you coming they see you
down the block and they cross to the
opposite side walk they will literally
walk through a park to avoid you I've
had some surreal moment I you know like
Richard Belzer like bought everybody
chicken parm sandwiches or whatever so
it's just weird to have him come out you
know and like oh one day the picket line
like Whoopi Goldberg shut up for comment
so it's kind of weird when you look over
your shoulder Whoopi Goldberg saying
they're you kind of do it a little bit
of told ya so there's been a couple of
surreal moments I think going the first
time and seeing the rat like the giant
fly table right like that was kind of a
thrill right that's you know you'd seen
the rat a million times on TV or in the
paper and it's like there he is right
and i had thought the rat was only for
like scab labor I did too and so that
was I didn't realize that he's just
there for strikes and whatever and
sometimes the rat can't make it and they
have that they have the inflatable pig
instead write the pig but I had yeah I
like the rat much but I make kind of a
traditionalist like the rat I am
constantly surprised at all the people
to honk at you in solidarity i did not
realize how much of the world is
actually unionized yes everybody from
taxi drivers Buster's furniture delivery
and although in the beginning like
somebody would come by like a trucker
would come by and honk and everybody
would kind of lift up their signs and
stuff and bind this point someone does
it say yeah you do